our radio drama this week talks about
mixing browsers and greases please
listen lend us Nemea ekq oh no is the
brains behind a radio initiative
designed to reach out to Nigeria's
farmers and teach them about sustainable
farming methods smallholder farmers
rural radio reaches 3,300 listeners in
around 6 communities in southeastern
Nigeria in the area of the right
practice you know the right spacing of
crops is something that it's very
relevant it's part of the things we
teach farmers on radio how to apply
fertilizer and when to apply fertilizer
you know we're teaching farmers
different methods in post harvest
management of green agriculture accounts
for just over 20 percent of Nigeria's
GDP but 70% of the country's working
population is employed in the sector one
major problem farmers say is flooding in
fact it has been a problem because of
weather changes as we are in Africa
witness some years ago that things are
not moving as expected on that much it
affects agric 61 year old farmer paul a
neem cultivates mainly rice yams and
cassava on his three acre farm in a
banya state in southern Nigeria even
with the crude method of farming he's
known on his life he's able to produce
40 to 50 bags of rice every year but he
says financing is a problem farmers in
Angeles nobody supporting them with
finance nobody if the baby finest don't
read it on the table go and shade that
morning no one we reach our hand as well
as broadcasting from the station ek
guano also goes out to hear what the
people think
he's convinced that since he started his
radio show in 2007 it's had a positive
influence on people's actions you know
in doing this warden identified it's a
strength of community decision what a
community comes in a sense that
everybody comes in by 10:00 p.m. you
know any community people rebel against
that law but everybody at the end of the
day sticks to it it's not only
fertilizers seeds and weed killers that
Nigeria's farmers need to know about
because of climate change it's important
for them to learn about improving
farming techniques and how they can
better adapt